i'm gonna go to the town center and i'm
gonna get a british flag i'm gonna put
petrol over it and i'm gonna install the
flag and i'm gonna insult churchill
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below you can also
use the discount code salam 10 for 10
of their products okay guys so basically
what's your name
okay kev kev came here and he said ali
wave the british flag now i said why do
you need me to raise the british flag
what's the reason but i wanted to make a
point he allowed me to use the flag with
consent yeah okay i want to ask you a
question yeah
i used to live in a town called grimsby
has everyone heard of grimsby okay i
used to live there i used to get into
trouble in london before i came to islam
i actually involved in gangs and stuff
like that yeah i think you need to pay
me royalties for this please sir yeah
thank you uh anyways so i used to live
there for about five six years i used to
get into a lot of fights i used to be
called p-a-k-i all day every day even
though i'm kurdish yeah
and so it's a very racist town i used to
get into fights day in day out
if i go to grimsby
and they are quite i would say british
nationalist you know they're proud
if i have this flag
and i set it on fire
i set you on fire i put petrol over it i
set you on fire and i say i hate britain
what would happen to me
do you think would happen to me
are we attacked in what way like slapped
punched stabbed
potentially potentially
are they to blame what am i to blame
if that happened
so if i went out my way
say that again okay okay
so so basically
okay i i leave my i leave london i
travel all the way to north i'm like
where is the most national british
nationalist grimsby i'm going to go all
the way to grimsby i'm going to go to
the town center and i'm going to get
british flag i'm going to put petrol
over it and i'm going to install the
flag and i'm going to insult churchill
and i'm going to say
i might use to blame at this interest
and i'm getting attacked imagine
somebody comes with a baseball bat yeah
and they're attacking me
are they to blame or am i to blame
technically
so they they are to blame technically
but then my view would be why are you so
stupid enough to be sat there
with a union jack and provoke people
provoking people by burning why'd you do
that that's a good question so the
reason why i'm doing this question
what's your name survivor tom hiding tom
you're right all right yes i like the
swagger by the way yes i'm working on
mine but it's still at the bottom
yes so now the question is the following
freedom of speech does it really exist
does the formula when we apply it to
really work it doesn't and what happened
is that for example we have people who
come and insult islam they insult the
quran they install the prophet muhammad
and people make it seem and by the way
sorry
kev sorry kim yeah so the thing is here
people make it seem like it's exclusive
to islam it's only the muslims that
can't deal with freedom of speech and
while i hold in a second if i want to
peck him who's wrong pick him mom i know
you're from cameraman relax yourself
leave up the end if i if i'm picking
yeah if i went to peckham a black
community and i had and i said i hate
n-i-g-g-e-r-s
do you think the people in pekka would
be like look mate
you know will you have a right to
freedom of speech and we're gonna what
would happen to me
i think there might be a drive-by i
think there might be a little drive-by
let's be real here yeah
the point is the following
every community has individuals who
might say look like for example we have
people come in and stop the prophet i
ignore them i've got time for them
that's hate i don't i don't want
anything to do with that i do my thing
but there are also people in our
communities muslims who would go and do
something crazy that happened two weeks
ago right the question is this is it
exclusive to islam no it's not because
if i was to go to grimsby a brit and and
there was like i had a lot of white meat
to this day i have one meat yeah if i
went to them and i said i hate churchill
churches
and i burnt the flag i'm not going to
expect them to say well ali you know we
defend your freedom of speech of course
you're not and we know what happened to
tommy robinson's march when me and
muhammad we nearly got killed yeah and
we went and
okay okay all right let's i've got
punched we got punched let's see yeah
let's say we've got punch yet but if
they had the means i think they wouldn't
let us live the point is this and i was
invited to tommy robinson's event it
wasn't that i went there i didn't turn
up like without being invited i was
invited to give it's a freedom of speech
event but i will stop because i'm a
muslim the point here is and the reason
why i was stopped is because the fla the
lads alliance said to tommy robinson if
he goes up there he's not coming down
yeah so the point here is the following
that if people are provoked there's
you're an idiot i'll be an idiot to go
to grimsby hold that flag and burn it
and i will be to blame and he said
absolutely and i admire your honesty and
this is what we need to talk about here
because people make it seem like it's
only the muslims that get upset no we're
not the only people that get upset
anyone would if this was a
well it's not christian country anymore
in that in that sense there is a lot of
atheist atheism if i went to russia
quite christian orthodox and i went and
insulted the church i'm gonna get kicked
in the face
the point i'm trying to make here is
freedom of speech is a dream and in real
life it doesn't exist
would
[Music]
if you were to go to grimsby yeah and
burn a british flag yeah and you'd get
beaten up the people who are beating you
up for doing uh morally legally however
you want to conceptualize it yeah
they're doing are doing a wrong action
oh oh can you give me that sorry sir
sorry
come come here
yeah if someone else commits a wrong axe
yes that justifies you doing a lot
like one one right one
but that's my point what i'm saying is
i'm not saying just because someone else
does i'm going to do it i'm making a
point here i would never do that
i i would i would never do that okay i
could never i would never do that my
point isn't following away from i'm from
edgware edgeway yeah your background
you're british
complicated you want britain to be a
barbarish
i'm not sure i'm not sure what that
means neither do i
i heard it somewhere so the point is
this year
is if someone provokes a group of
individuals yeah do we agree that there
will be people who might come
but we can we can separate between the
kind of the fact that there will be
consequences we can separate from that
where there should or shouldn't be
consequences no no no no
their flag doesn't employ moral judgment
no no but you're and then you're
deriving moral charges no no would there
be an action to the to that they would
but that doesn't imply anything about
what what that you have the right to do
or not no i'm not saying i've never said
they do i want to do it
so you're inferring from you're
inferring from kind of facts about how
people behave in immoral ways facts
about what should and shouldn't happen
so you're so you're inferring from the
actions of immoral people what actions
are moral or not and i take objections
no no no what i'm saying is the
following if a group an individual here
provokes a certain group of people
and that person is attacked yes
they have provoked and they play a part
in that because they've provoked it and
that is
the point is what they are not that's
the question the point is within some
reasonable boundary exactly what that is
we can help the people who carry their
attack don't follow the reasonable
balance right right but you're what
you're doing further on in your argument
let me make sure i've understood your
argument correctly so your argument is
is you you you're certain and i and i
think you're probably broadly on the
money here that if you were to go to
x place and do y action which was in
your legal moral rights league will kind
of ignore any distinction between
legality morality for the purpose of
this argument because that's the thing
you can do with another you're saying if
we were to go to that situation and then
you were to get attacked
you know so you're you're deriving from
that that freedom of speech shouldn't
exist
it doesn't it doesn't
well no so but that's not quite what
freedom of speech means
you're deriving a fact from how immoral
people behave in a way which we agree is
wrong yes as in we all agree i think
everybody would agree here however much
we could have an argument about your
right to burn the flag or not we would
agree that anyone who beat you up yeah
on in virtue of that has committed a
morally
insane it's a legal crime
well it's a legal crime but you're the
application of freedom of speech do we
see the effects of it working we're not
working
you're deriving moral facts from immoral
people you're you're deriving facts
about the world
from the way that it is but but not even
from the way
but you're not dealing you're not you're
saying you're not deriving it from a
fact based upon how you think the world
should morally be
driving no you're you're not it's free
speech is a dream based not just a fact
so you're so you're deriving what you're
doing is you're saying there are people
who behave in ways we disagree with yes
okay and you're deriving from a fact
about that
people behave no no
no no surely what you should be looking
for that's dreaming
surely what you should be looking
towards is a world in which people
accept enough extent of freedom of
speech to the extent that if they see
you burning a british flag their
response is not and and freedom of
speech does not mean the response does
not mean you you kind of have the right
to then does not mean you have the right
to not have the consequence in terms of
that someone can't have an argument with
you about that all we're saying is
all we're asking or
all you want is you you want you want
the right child to burn a flag or do
some other provocative act and you just
want to be not attacked i don't think
that's a dream i think the right that
you can do
and then not be beaten tonight i think
that's that is an absolute dream let me
tell you something because hey everybody
okay
i think you have to unpick what you mean
by that i don't know but that could be
in the past can i connect because no one
thinks so so certainly
you ask me a question
the point here is this look i would love
a world where we hold hands like hippies
run around yeah i don't know go for a
jog or whatever broth that's a dream
world
no no
sir what's your name questioning adam
listen to me please i've listened to you
what you're doing no no i have
understood
but i don't know i don't know i don't
know if you've understood me because the
thing is the following okay freedom of
speech is a dream
the reason why it's a dream is because
we can see the consequences for example
charlie hebdo drew the prophet
characters or characters of the prophet
right yes the whole world went on a mad
one like in the context where that's
their freedom of speech
last week somebody draw drew macron as
hitler and hitler's and macron is suing
them
macron the guy who's freedom of speech
advocate is now suing but what are you
saying
one second freedom of speech doesn't
mean the right to say whatever you want
no
ah one second no no
no one's claiming that freedom of speech
is what's it so what's everyone's
claiming that freedom of speech is the
right say whatever you want in any
context
clearly well we clearly agree
in terms of conditions well so if
there's limits of freedom of speech
okay everything now we're talking about
so so we agree that an incitement to
violence so we are so there's lots of
different ways you can kind of do this
like so there's what the most obvious
one is an incitement to violence so that
is if if if someone stands up in
speaker's corner and says well so not
violent incitement to violence
yeah so we agree there's also so also
actions which kind of limit so it
depends exactly you can take a
complicated view on exactly why you
think you want free speech to be
valuable yeah so i i would
i would typically take the view that
it's a necessary condition for a
functioning democracy and so that kind
of gives you some limits and so we can
agree that if you if you speak in such a
way that limits the ability of others to
speak freely in the sense that you
degrade another population or great
degrade another group so the most
classic example of this is racist
behavior so if you speak in a racist way
that's problematic obviously because
it's effective why is it problematic
well it's problematic and effusive
in hatred so it's problematic so if you
start to get horrible i might run
it so if it's problematic so even if
it's not incitement to violence so the
reason why we want free speech in the
first place have a functioning democracy
used to question the government right
right exactly and that's part of it
so let me explain so what's part of that
is you need all the different groups in
society to be able to have an input into
the democratic process okay and so the
problem is if i say something racist
which then to get degrades the ability
of another group in society to say what
they to express their opinion so if i
was to say all people of x group are
stupid and i'm in a position of such
authority i'm clearly not but if i was
in such a position of authorities that
all people in group x are stupid enough
such their opinions shouldn't be valued
in that so then what if i can do that
enough times and have enough impact on
enough people then what i can do is i
can diminish from the functioning of
democracy because i can stop that group
from participating
okay
but in reality you go like me in
practice yeah you get one yeah but
in practice when you apply when you
apply it it doesn't work it doesn't sir
i'm asking the same question yeah
you go to a
go to black predominately black area i
think you haven't understood no no no no
i i have but i think we're talking about
a bit two separate things here you ask
me why yeah yeah no no no no no no no no
no no no that's fine do you reject do
you believe okay no no no no
no no no no no no no
no no you said for example a person of a
stature makes a comment about a group of
people yeah to a certain extent that
they are disregarded that undermines
them that undermines them yes okay that
means that do you believe in democracy
no i don't believe in the democrats
i believe in islamic uh law
so so so because what god said i believe
that's the best for humankind what what
if i believe that for myself no if i'm i
have to be wrong i'm proven proven
recording that's improvement that's the
good thing about democracy
i'm wrong
as a person that advocates democracy you
are saying i'm very happy for you to
express what i want to try and express
it within the boundaries well you're not
allowing me
i never hit me out yet i'm saying in
practice
if you go to a predominantly black area
community and you use the n-word yes
what would happen to you well you're not
very nice things no no but why not why
why the freedom of speech well because
well so remember that so that's that's a
very different question why why that's
my
so the point is is there's a difference
between the practice of the way
different people interpret freedom of
speech so if if there are some people
out there who don't respect well so it
depends in the context in which you're
using it and it's and it's almost
certainly an unacceptable thing to say
and i would agree anyone who says it
isn't but but isn't is in the black
community then limiting my freedom of
speech well
yes they are but it's justified but it's
justified for the reason i've just
explained it so okay one second which is
so if somebody so
so no i'm not just having i'm just about
to say i'm not just finding there's
nothing
there should be something no no no no
one second who is at fault we are some
people here they say you win because
because you're provoking them no no
you're an idiot
psychology what you're saying is guys
i'm going to insult you and call you the
n word you can't do nothing about it
let's see
no no no no no but there are people who
are not going to insult but want to get
violent yeah sure and then they'll go to
jail no problem they can go to jail but
does that exist within our community yes
if that exists within our community then
does the application of freedom of
speech work or doesn't work
wait wait wait say that again okay if it
if you're gonna have in any group muslim
christian jewish black white green blue
aliens yeah yeah
if we go and insult them
and provoke them and they it's different
when you're insulting you're provoking
yeah
well they might know the same but one
leads to another if you're insulting and
it provokes them so the point is the
following that if an individual does
that continuously and there are group of
people in that community who say ignore
there are a group of people in the
mississippi what i'm saying is
what i'm saying is what i'm saying
it's not all right
let me finish it because you're
diminishing no it's not can i make my
point one second it is i'm disagreeing
with both let me finish
if i if a group of people say we will
ignore that person who spirits hate
another person says we'll swear back and
another group of people say we will try
to punch them physically okay the point
here is the following the application of
freedom of speech doesn't apply and work
in the real world
am i right or wrong
okay okay that's more interesting
actually um
i don't think it's consistently applied
but could it be consistently applied i
think so yeah
as in so for example i don't think we
actually adhere to proper freedom of
speech which would be to say you can
basically say anything irrespective of
how insulting it is as long as it's not
an incitement to violence okay so if
someone is not inciting to violence but
they go out and do this and a group of
or an individual yeah an individual
decides to take action physically
who is to blame